welcome to another technology tuesday
today i've got a special treat with you
i'm going to share with you
the 18 websites that i look at every
single
day when i open my computer in the
morning these are the 18 sites that i
always check out
and people keep asking me about my
schedule and what i'm looking at so
these are the 18 sites that i look at
every single day
and hopefully you can learn from them as
well okay so this is my homepage
dashboard it's a file that i
i save on my local computer that i load
up every single morning that has all the
important things that i
need to run my business i have my
personal suppliers business these are
like my daily tools i use but
this side where it says daily these are
the things that i do every single day
and i'm going to load them up
and walk you through what i do with them
so let's load each one up
in a different tab and we'll go through
them
one by one so two of them are actually
on the site and they're here
these two are the google hot searches
this is from the united states and this
is from canada this is a plug-in that
you could put in on any website
to basically show you what people are
searching so these are the most popular
searches
in the united states that are happening
right now and it shows you how
popular they are by this this red bar uh
it's it's christmas eve when i'm
recording this so you can see things
like felice navidad is the season
joyer noel is is french for merry
christmas
uh so you can see that these are the
things that are trending and if i don't
know what something is
uh then i can easily click through and
learn about it so helena bonham carter
was in the news for some reason i don't
know why
she split up after 13 years with tim
burton so you know
easy way to know what people are
searching for and why
it's important okay so we're going to go
through each of these one by one
so next is facebook and facebook
hey i see my year in review there we go
me and nina
so this facebook is just to see if i
have any messages uh
i don't spend a lot of time i typically
just check out the first post
and and and that's it i don't spend too
much time kind of digging deep into
what people are saying i use it to kind
of keep in touch with
my wife is usually off working so she
already messaged me
and what does she want pretty good video
about how a homeless man spent
given a hundred dollars cool we'll
watch thanks babe
so i usually actually keep it open
during the day it's my easiest way to
get to
connect with my wife and anybody who
really needs to get a hold of me quickly
next is music i have a custom page
that is my believe playlist and these
are some of the songs that i listen to
that keeps me inspired motivated
again i need to have music in the
morning to to get me
moving and you want to create your own
belief playlist as well so i have
how many songs on here 85 songs and
groin
and just songs that i like get me
dancing kept me moving in the morning
again one of the first pages that i load
and you want to have
a playlist of your own that gets you
excited every morning
next this is my my business page uh
so my facebook page i'll usually just
look at the messages here i don't check
out any of the content i look at the
messages
and see who i have to get back to so
people who are asking me questions
um and so i'll write back to them
quickly so just social media checkup
here i have my my lists so i have a
couple of lists that i use
um i don't check the main facebook
stream too much because i find it too
overwhelming
and and you just get lost in it so i
created a couple lists
family business healthy living and and
my own
page so here things are related to my
family that i can scroll down on
business i have some some clients and
various business things related here so
basically the pages that i'm a fan of so
toronto dance salsa um is one of the
investments i have
sage and aweber companies i'm working
with
and so i can easily check out what
they're posting and comment
healthy living are just things that i
find interesting some pages healthy
holistic living has some great content
i love my family has some great content
and just
i can easily scan it see what new things
here's a cute video and
i love using the facebook list as a way
to keep track of the important content
that i want to see
every day instead of just getting it
buried and a lot of the facebook pages
now are getting buried
in your main news feed and you'll never
see the content that shows up so i
specifically
created it for that and then i have my
own page here
and i'll just see what people are are
sharing
and you know like them comment them
respond to people
so these are the people on my team as
well as my own
posts next i move over to hootsuite
and hootsuite is what i use for twitter
i'll take a quick look
at my scent tweets these are my family
so my sister's been posting
some stuff she works at the united
nations and so she has she's doing a
whole bunch of ebola stuff right now so
she's posting pictures and good way to
know what she's up to
uh i have a list of baseball staff so
people that i follow on baseball
and again twitter is such a crazy stream
you need to create your own list to be
able to maintain the data that comes in
uh so i like keeping track of what's
happening in the off season
here these are from my movement students
and what they're posting
so you know jen posted this rich posted
this i can go check out the videos that
they're posting their comments
keep on touch business again a list of
people who i want to follow for business
reasons so sage cindy bates is a
vice president i believe at microsoft
people who relate to one word so they're
all custom lists that i made on twitter
and you can bring them into hootsuite
easily so jessica alba has her one word
of honesty
uh 3m has innovation and so a few
few companies are using their one word
and why my direct message inbox so
people can connect with me
and then my mentions and i can see you
know new mentions people i want to write
back to and i try to write back to
everybody
and i just find this as an easy way to
connect with everybody
next is unfollowers these are people who
are not following me anymore so
i will just quickly look at who is not
following me back anymore
and i will unfollow them
next is google plus and i just take a
quick look at what's happening on google
plus
and i'll try to usually just comment on
the first one that i see
either this or this i'll leave a comment
on just to say great video or
good post if i like it just an easy
quick way to uh
to stay in touch i do a small business
champion of the day
and i find this super helpful i combine
this with my
hootsuite one of the things i found on
twitter was i couldn't remember who i
last responded to or not so if i look at
my mentions here
you know who did i last respond to where
do i leave off because i only check
twitter once a day i don't have time to
stay on twitter all day long
and so who did i last respond to i don't
want to go back to my scent and try to
find it
so what i do every day is i post
an evan carmichael small business
champion of the day
and whoever it is and this is randomly
generated from people who
i like their stuff i respect what
they're doing in the entrepreneurship
community
and then i post it and then i know that
everything after that post is new stuff
so for example this is what i posted
this morning at 8 10 in the morning
so now i know i have to go to go through
all of these tweets that mention me
until i get to the next one by me so i
go all the way through
this is what i responded to this morning
lots of these tweets
from here the oven chemical small
business champion of this these are my
mentions and i make sure to mention
myself so it'll show up in the stream
so then tomorrow i'll do a new one and i
know i have to go through all of these
new ones until i get to
here and this is the easiest way i've
found to
track what i'm doing on twitter and not
have it monopolize my life
next is linkedin just quickly check my
messages i don't spend a lot of time on
linkedin
but i like to really get back to people
who do inbox me so
that's empty because i cleared it this
morning clout
uh cloud sometimes has some interesting
content around entrepreneurship so you
should take a quick look at it to see if
they have any
what's happening here oh clout what kind
of experience is this
this is terrible charming date
okay well i might have to remove clout
let's try that one more time
clout fail sign in with twitter
it's gonna work this time there we go
that was messed up
so clout gives me ideas for content and
i usually don't do anything with it i
just like looking at it to see if
there's something interesting in the
entrepreneurial world
so they have tags i use entrepreneurship
and small business
and it shows me related content that i
can pull up their articles
and so sometimes there's some
interesting things
i don't know if anything would be
pulling out for this but
i haven't looked at it and actually
posted anything for a while but it's
cool to see what
kind of content is coming out that
entrepreneurs are talking about you got
to stay on top of your market
amazon these are deals of the day and
just quickly look i'm
curious to see what's happening on
amazon i got amazon prime so i get free
two-day shipping and just see what's
interesting every now and then i'll make
a purchase but
uh quick quick browsing to see what's
there kickstarter i love kickstarter and
i love
toronto and city so i look at
kickstarter toronto every day to see
what projects i've backed a couple
i have uh connected with the
entrepreneurs for a few
and and partnered with them and given
them exposure
so i like seeing what toronto
entrepreneurs are up to and there's any
way that
i can help or i find it interesting so
quick look at that there aren't that
many that come out every day so it's
pretty quick to go through
google play i look at the top three apps
on android and this is just to get a
sense of what people are looking
at and what apps are popular and you
know what i'm missing out on
and i'm not a huge mobile user
i don't have a data plan i don't have a
phone number although i have a cell
phone i use it more
more like an ipad i guess but i like
seeing what apps are out there what's
popular what's trending just to stay
current
it's just a quick glance then i go to my
youtube comments and this
this is the heart this is what i love
this is this is the fuel for me
and see what people are talking about
and writing about
and and i respond i respond to like you
can see here are comments and i'm
responding to basically everybody who
who writes a comment um it's
it's what i love doing every single day
and and kind of
gives me that energy to keep going so
thank you guys so much you can see this
is still just from a day ago i get
so many comments and it's christmas eve
so this is actually slow it's usually
crazy crazy crazy busy but it's still
just one day ago as we scroll down down
down down down down
so uh yeah i mean the heart of what i do
and you want to have those little why's
to help keep you motivated every day
and then this is product hunt and
product hunt is what people
put up to share and kind of new ideas
that are on the web that can help
businesses grow i usually miss today and
go the day before to see what the most
popular one was
so command line radio for geeks easy way
to keep up with industry news and
inspiration
expand your knowledge universe in five
minutes a day free ebook
you know i see what's popular so these
are all upvoted so this is the most
popular one
it is it is uh skewed towards geeks
trending
um technology that kind of stuff but i
like it and every now and then i find
some cool sites that i can
easily use myself or share with friends
and the last one is the newest one
uh famebit and this is a way for people
who are on youtube to collaborate with
each other
and so i've collaborated with a whole
bunch of people
right now it's mostly the people on here
are mostly in kind of makeup beauty
space but there's a few that aren't
and i've reached out to them some
reached out to me and basically that
trying to find ways to collaborate if
you think about musicians you know it's
common to
be on each other's albums and record
songs together so youtubers are starting
to do that too where
you know i'll be on your channel if
you're on my channel we'll be on the
same video together
this one is an example it's a channel
with 196 000 subscribers
and she wanted to do a mashup of a bunch
of youtube people
sharing one minute of why youtube has
changed their life and so i recorded a
quick one minute
for her and that's going to go up on on
her channel and so just a great way to
check in to see what new
youtubers are out there looking for
collaborations to work together
so those are the 18 sites that i look at
every single day
to fuel me and help my business grow i'd
love to hear what are the must-have
sites that you need to check out every
single day leave them in the comments
below maybe i'll discover something new
i haven't heard of below
let that comment fly let let that
inspire other entrepreneurs to go check
it out too
if you guys like this video you want to
see more subscribe to the channel thank
you so much for watching
and i'll see you soon
if you want to see more great content to
keep you inspired
motivated and believing check out my
newsletter in the link below